Eric Trump was reportedly spat on by a
waitress at a Chicago restaurant last
night the President signed telling
Breitbart about the disturbing incident
saying quote it was purely a disgusting
act with somebody who clearly has
emotional problems for a party that
preaches tolerance this once again
demonstrates they have very little
civility when someone is sick enough to
resort to spitting on someone it just
emphasizes a sickness and desperation
and the fact that were winning end quote
the unidentified employee was reportedly
released from police custody after Eric
declined to press charges and we should
say that Larry Trump will also be on
with martha maccallum at 7 o'clock to
discuss this I'm sure about other issues
about the campaign so Greg yes how do
you respond to it tolerance once again
first of all it's interesting how these
stories are never hoaxes whenever you
hear them you execute to blame the guy
who spit or the Vandal the person who
punched someone or the person who Doc's
the kid at school but you realize it a
lot of the responsibility is the media
that has raised the temperature in the
last couple years in push division the
Trump family can't possibly be as bad as
what the media says that they are it's
impossible actually but they push it
they push it
that's why Smollett chased his path
that's why people attacked Trump
supporters that's what politics is now a
personal vendetta we have the soccer
player right what's her name rappin a-ok
no one knows the hell who she is until
she does this then she becomes a
protected class she expands her media
footprint by screaming infantile pap
so the self-centered athletes causes the
sports money but she's trending by being
a selfish grandstander this is the same
problem the media makes it so that
people think this might help them or
make this emotionally gratifying thing
by attacking somebody but you just look
like a loser so Jesse Eric Trump is not
pressing charges nice guy and Secret
Service also took a look at who this
person is we can repeatedly see this
happening now and it gets justified as
as okay because the president's
destroying the country somehow and
therefore they're validated in their
actions right now you know Juan's making
a face but I came prepared with a whole
long list of violent attacks on Trump
for the last two and half years it's a
very long list gotta be twins go through
you stacks with crowbars throwing bricks
through windows including burning an
animal carcass and leaving it on
someone's stoop
I mean don't forget to subscribes that
are blamed on trucks exactly I know you
can say there's other things from the
riot that they've done of course we all
know what they are but the overwhelming
amount of violence is coming from the
left imagine if this had been Chelsea
Clinton imagine if this had been Malia
Obama or any son or daughter of a
Democrat president